hey blog can you capture that footage
whenever you cut capture just run it
vlog I just tore my ACL I think
[Music]
so but yes the fifth book I'm excited
about it my crush it wasn't the biggest
book I wrote because it's it was the
first one so this is the follow-up 201
yeah exactly this is the follow-up to it
and and it's just super relevant like
it's basically like the first several
the first kind of part of it part one is
like just complete mind set like [ __ ]
man like do you understand that if you
have four hundred thirteen thousand
dollars in college debt like outcome
from alcoholic parents and like work at
like Saks Fifth Avenue that's still
still at 7:30 when you get home from
your [ __ ] hour-and-a-half commute
still you can take your [ __ ] phone
out and do damage for five hours and
over the course of six years turnaround
that ridiculously impossible narrative
that you're stuck in the fact that
that's true is batshit crazy yeah when I
wrote the first one people are like what
go on YouTube make a living wait what be
the the king of honey and make ninety
thousand a year instead of making
seventy two like I do I think you and I
are anomalies I do not think that sucked
like somebody in Cincinnati right now
who makes 47 K working retail can't make
51 being the biggest expert on Star Trek
like I don't think people understand the
longtail sure like it's that's a big
[ __ ] deal the variable difference of
happiness of making 81 K in upper
management and something that makes you
miserable versus making 64 talking about
wiffle ball all day is a big deal to me
it's just about happiness and I just
think that a lot of people don't realize
how much they know about a very narrow
niche that also has a ton of other
people that are into it and if they
understand how to use Instagram YouTube
Facebook and podcasting like they just
can't understand how much money there is
heading upstairs to a meeting it's
always fun when you have a client or
potential client within your own
building I think I need to kind of
figure out what all that long ago I do
is so huge it's getting really cluttered
and it's getting really like this can I
give you can I give you a quick piece of
advice every world is like that yeah
don't let that [ __ ] you and go narrow
to what makes you pop motivational
speakers are my most hated people yet I
hate that yet I get categorized in that
world all the time right but I'm not
crippled because I know that I'm not
trying to do the wrong thing right the
wrong thing this is by forget about that
if you don't ever look for the white
space that doesn't exist
yeah do what the [ __ ] you know what you
like if you know yoga
yoga's plenty [ __ ] khattak you know
yeah being the cream rises to the top
business not in the I'm gonna see
something nobody else sees business so
all the people that are doing the wrong
thing crowded not authentic it just has
nothing to do with you I'm not crippled
by other agencies sucking up giving a
[ __ ] about people that's the thing you
need to do a lot of risky and I'm like I
don't know ask you from just don't
believe in this whole notion of like
okay you graduated you can you can pick
up back from come back work here I'm in
the same spot yeah I also just don't
actually think it's the other ways risky
I me too because I think it's really
easy to become complacent and a hundred
percent I don't I don't know I don't
think it's deviating from a path cause I
don't think there is a path there's way
too much respect for anybody who thinks
what you're doing is risky yeah I mean
I've literally got no response from like
one person but like my family is like
yes 100%
like and there's so and the person
that's you know saying that is you know
respects a certain narrative and that's
awesome - that's and may be great for
them forever
yeah maybe going with Ryan Harwood right
here Co pure Wow very smart and handsome
going to see a potential client for
well banner X baby Alex I'm sending an
email to the company asking who's an
Eagles fan and yeah and they're gonna
email you that they're Neagle span put
in a folder okay if you're a real
Philadelphia Eagles fan and work at
vaynermedia please email Alexandria that
you are please email alexandre aja she's
see seed here and then the body don't
lie sent that I love everybody be like
what about Patriot fans not sending any
[ __ ] Patriot fans to Super Ball but
for Eagle fans from vaynermedia are
going Andy placing some ads getting back
to your roots and doing something
I don't even know what I'm doing I'm
like what is this machine known as the
computer
[Music]
my guy how you doing man I've been
looking forward to this man I'm looking
forward to it what's up man I I [ __ ]
with you heavy as [ __ ] like like I'm
putting I think you guys know I'm
putting you on blatt like I'm I'm on the
record of who I think is next and it's
you because I have that like I know my
ear which is like I don't think I'm
anything like I don't even like to talk
to music people about music but I know
me and I know like I just know I'm gonna
honestly I'm a very serious no man I
really really really think you've got
the absolute exact right thing for
what's about to happen I just think you
need to you know my big thing is
collaborations and volume like you guys
do you that's always my thing like to me
I just want you to do more [ __ ] like you
know like artists always like it's
always tricky with my advice to artists
cuz I want more volume and artists can
run like they don't want to dilute it
they want it to be like part like I have
empathy but I know it's right cuz cuz
the here's what people to understand
with volume they remember the hits they
forget the other [ __ ] you don't have the
potential to suck you understand that
right like like if I was like hey you
but but yeah do you understand what I
mean like if I was like yo you have to
put out a hundred songs in a row you're
weakest one of those hundred in my
opinion isn't gonna be weak enough to
[ __ ] you up and the upside of a hundred
[ __ ] at-bats I believe in that [ __ ]
and then collaborations like like [ __ ] I
think I was just listening to one of
yours for [ __ ] we just now let me see
this would be great yep it's literally
literally what I'm listening to
yeah like right like this like as many
of those as possible I can't say it
enough man
it's just how music like you guys are in
it and you know it better than me I just
know what humans do that's why I'm gonna
do my thing
it's just that bad people don't get it
it's just tomorrow song that changes
everything I get that's why I like
Twilight room I like rust because he's
competitive and chip-on-the-shoulder
like it's all based on versions of my
own personality you're talking truth and
you're not scared to go into territories
that don't look the part that's it you
know it's fun you know it's funny about
that
Mike one of my favorite things I say
ever I say a lot of [ __ ] is uh money
doesn't change you it just exposes you
like I'm not like I said this to crit
like I'm not like a real music guide the
reason I [ __ ] with you is what you're
saying like like I like the story you
know I like that you're going to places
that I think are vulnerable and truth
cuz that guy will and that girl will
always win that's what people are saying
about POC and Biggie go go like actually
go back and listen to POC and they were
talking about like you guys are
youngsters like you don't understand
like Brenda's got a baby like that was a
that was ridiculous like that was [ __ ]
like like like biggie like and just like
storytelling right like Biggie's funny
like I got a story to tell you was funny
like it's that was different this was
when hip-hop was like I'm hardcore like
I'm tough and you're not simple binary
there was no other story so they're
vulnerable don't get why they broke out
for a million reasons but nobody I mean
I watch every documentary I read
everything and I'm waiting for somebody
to say those guys broke out they say
storytellers they'll compare them to K R
Us one things like that's fine
it's the vulnerability my advice go in a
cocoon meaning like go out do live like
but like mentally being a cook like
anything that beers you from
dominating be out there you go out every
night but don't get caught up in
anything that veered like you need to be
obsessed cuz gifts are [ __ ] rare man
my guy and I'm really rooting for you
please good to see you don't ever wear
that Jersey non-game let's go okay I
love it
thank you see ya yeah yeah hey blog can
you capture that footage
whatever you cut capture just run it
blog I just tore my ACL I think the
elevator just destroyed my knee but
that's what you have to do when you
[ __ ] hustle stick your leg in the
elevator to save that 28 seconds in my
count
[Music]